[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK CHMARNY: Welcome for
coming to our sessions
on Knative Eventing.
I'm Mark Chmarny.
I'm one of the technical
program editors at Google
looking after serverless.
VILLE AIKAS: And
I'm Ville Aikas.
I work on the Knative.
I've been working on
it from the beginning.
And most recently I've been
working on the eventing
side of the Knative.
So that's what we're
talking about today.
MARK CHMARNY: First of
all, thank you for coming.
I know this is the last
day of the conference,
and even getting this
audience here is great.
And it also is going to
be a 300 level session.
So we're going to go a
little deeper in technology.
We're going to do
all kinds of demos--
well, at least two
demos, maybe three.
There's going to be
a cube STL commands.
There are going to be yaml.
So definitely,
definitely lots of fun.
The other thing I want to kind
of quickly just give a heads up
is we've recently
this week we dropped
a new version of Knative.
So everything we're
going to be showing today
is based on dead
version of Knative
that just landed this week.
There is a blog post that we
published earlier this morning
that overviews all the new
features in 05 of Knative.
Don't read right now.
But later, later on.
By the way the, Dory is
also open for the session.
So Ville and I are
here, obviously,
so we're not going to be
able to answer real time.
But as soon as
this is over we'll
jump in and provide answers.
And hopefully we'll
have some time also
to take real time questions.
All right.
So very quickly.
How many of you worked
on or touch Knative,
or use Knative, worked
on Knative in any kind
of interaction with Knative?
All right.
So we have some
people, but not many.
So why don't we
take a quick kind
of level 100 overview of
Knative for about three to five
minutes.
And then we can go deeper
into it once we level set.
First of all, Knative is a set
of open source building blocks
that are specifically
kind of oriented
for building serverless
on top of Kubernetes.
What that means is that last
July at this very conference
we have launched Knative
as an open source project.
And we had at the time
four other partners
who worked with us on that.
We were very much focusing on
those building block concepts,
knowing that people can pick
and choose those components that
are needed.
But we also saw a
lot of commonality
that people were working
on in the community.
And while they were very
interesting and complex,
they were also not
very differentiating.
So people were often
not being able to get
as user-friendly experience
building service on Kubernetes
as [INAUDIBLE].
So we launched this.
It's on GitHub under
Apache 2 license.
And right from the start
we focused specifically
on three areas initially.
But the space is growing.
We focus on building, which
how do you get to an image
that you can actually
use on Kubernetes
that would be friendly for
serverless type of workloads.
We focus on eventing,
which we're going
to be talking about today.
And we focused on
serving, which is clearly
how you're going to be
accessing the serverless stock
at that time.
So very much still focusing on
these modern type of workloads.
What that means is that if you
have a stateful application,
this might not be a
good fit for Knative.
But if you're working in a
kind of modern stock 12 factor
applications,
microservices, this
is very much kind of
geared towards delivering
the best experience of
developing on top of Kubernetes
for you.
It also includes 10-plus years
of building serverless stock
at Google.
So all the learnings
from those products
are kind of applying
here, both from Google
as well as number of
partners in a community.
So that's pretty exciting.
So very quickly I'm
going to overview
each one of those components.
So we had a serving built in
events for Serving and Build
very quickly.
So a couple benefits the
developers get from Knative
today.
First of all, the one
that we always stress
is this automatic auto-scaling.
Basically, you
deploy the workload,
and we take care of this
underlining auto-scaling
based on requests or
usage of that workload.
Not on something like CPU, which
might be more traditional way
of auto-scaling for Kubernetes.
And what that means
is that we can
auto-scale through
activation when
their request is being made.
And then we also can
scale it down to 0
when that workload
is not being used,
which is very helpful for
obvious utilization reasons.
So if you have a
Kubernetes cluster,
that cluster can be used
to provide other services
or resources that can be
managed through other workloads.
The other very interesting
part for Serving
is that we kind of
from day one focused
on looking at deployments as
a combination of configuration
and the actual code.
So it goes in unit,
we freeze that.
We identify it.
We manage it for you.
And what that means that at any
given time you can roll back--
you can deploy a new
version and roll back
to the last previous
known state knowing
that it will go with
the configuration that
was true at the time.
If you've been
building applications,
the very common pattern
that we see over and over
is you come to a
conference like this.
You've seen some new language,
new framework, new service.
You get excited.
You build that service.
It goes live.
You startling get users.
Yay!
It's exciting.
And now you find out
that there is a bug.
Well, I would.
You write perfect code.
So that would not be the case
for your code, obviously.
And now you need to
update that application.
But you have users
who constantly use it.
So one of the things that
Knative enables you to do
is provide a way to manage
that and provides patterns
like blue/green, which
allows you to shadow
a new version behind and switch
the traffic to a new one,
and also use some kind
of experiment framework
that will allow you to
incrementally switch
the traffic to a new version.
Switch the traffic to a version
that's not exposed to the users
with a name route access it,
or any combination in between.
So a lot of good
learnings there.
The access control is the
last one I list there.
But this year just highlights.
So obviously we can go deeper
on that at any given time.
There's a lot of documentation.
So this deals with
the fact that you
might have-- if you're
building microservices,
sooner or later you
end up with 10, 20,
and if you're doing
it for a while,
it's going to be hundreds
of microservices.
And only one or
two of those need
to be externally accessible
with the request access path
control that's integrated.
Based on Istio in Knative,
you can manage that
by not exposing routes to
services that don't have
to be externally accessible.
So it's very helpful.
On a Build side,
right from the day one
we were focused on delivering
reproducible builds.
That comes very
critical if you want
to be able to assure that
the same version of code
built multiple times can
result in the exact same image.
And it also enables
us to start kind
of exposing through Build
templates ways for people
to optimize different frameworks
and different languages
for Build pipelines that allow
developers to go directly
from source all
the way to a URL.
So yes, there is an
image in between there.
But the developer
doesn't have to see it.
Eliminates a lot of pain
around cross-compiling.
Like number of flags, I
know like in Go is not
too complicated.
But if you go to Java, you want
to compile from Java on a Mac
to Java on Linux, you might
have some different challenges
there.
And also removes
the need for Docker
entirely on your
workstation, because it's
built on the service.
You send your Build job.
It compiles it.
It builds that image for you
and handles the entire thing.
And because it's a cloud scene,
it runs on top of Kubernetes,
you have access
to all the caching
and all the elasticity of that
framework of that service.
And you can leverage big
VMs for the build process.
And you can decommission
them afterwards
and use other nodes that maybe
are more optimized for bursting
type of workloads.
So that's excellent.
Very quickly, this is
just high level overview,
because for the rest
of this session,
we're going to go deep
into the eventing.
So eventing more
than anything is
all about orchestrating the
actual events on your cluster,
both for the event sources
that happen externally
to the cluster, as well as
if they happen on a cluster
itself.
One of the things that we
also focus from day one
is making sure that that
experience for the developer
is very declarative.
So you don't go in,
run some commands
that then suddenly you have
to rerun if the notes change.
But you tell us the
state that you want.
And using the same
principle that's
applicable to the
entire Kubernetes stack,
you get that event
registered and bound for you.
Higher level objects made it
much easier to reason about.
So you can kind of
always come back
and interrogate you
configuration to understand
what exactly has happened.
Even though you might
have set it up two weeks,
three weeks ago.
And because it's built
on top of those--
Knative events are
built on top of serving,
you continue getting access
to that dynamic scalability.
So it allows you to
build this very simple
triggered demonstration we're
going to show in a minute
here when you wire some kind
of event directly to a service,
and just fire it automatically
all the way to a very
complex pipeline.
And every day I'm
amazed by what people
are building-- channels,
triggers, filters, [INAUDIBLE],,
all kinds of stuff.
All of that is based on open
standard for event transport.
So cloud events is what we
utilize inside of Knative.
And on the end of this, on
the end of the day-- sorry--
is extendable.
So what that means
is that, yes, we
have I would say about 20
different sources that already
publish on the
Knative website that
are built by the community.
You can consume those.
You don't have to build this.
But you know what?
If one of those that
you need is not there,
you can always come back
and build a new one.
And Ville is going to show
you later how relatively easy
that can be for different
kind of use cases.
So without further ado,
let's talk about eventing.
VILLE AIKAS: Thanks, Mark.
All right.
So yeah.
So I'm really excited to go
ahead and be here and talk
about the new eventing model.
We have spent several
months in looking
at the use cases, how people
use the objects that we
put together in the--
I don't know-- .2.3 release,
and getting a lot of feedback
from the users on those, and
hearing it loud and clear
that they are pretty
tricky to put together.
When we started
the serving stat,
it was a little bit
easier because Kubernetes
had a lot of primitives
that we could use.
And they lent
themselves quite well
for building the serving stack.
For the eventing, not so much.
So we had to do a lot of
work on there making sure
that those primitives are
right so that we can then
build something really
neat on top of that.
So we are going to talk
about the two new objects
that we introduced.
If you have used
the eventing before,
there are other things in there.
But these are the two new
ones that we talk about,
because we think they make
the most sense as a user
to go ahead and reason about
the state of your system
and to make it useful.
So really the developer cares
about one thing and one thing
only, which is to
go and say, I want
to go ahead and take
events like this.
And I want to send
them over here.
If you think about it like
that, that makes sense to me.
So you don't really care about
where those events came from.
Right?
That should be a detail that you
shouldn't have to worry about.
You're just like, I just
want to go ahead and open
an object that's uploaded
to my storage, for example.
And when that happens,
do the thumb mailer.
The classic example.
But you do, however, care
about how these events show up
in your function.
And as Mark mentioned, we
are using Cloud events.
So it's a CNCF spec
that a lot of companies
are working on,
including Google.
So we are standing on the
shoulders of the great work
that other people
have been doing.
So we want to go and
emphasize the fact
that you as the
function developer
can go ahead and have a standard
way of consuming these events.
So you go and get
the cloud events.
And by using these two
new models with the broker
and trigger, we are really
unifying the consumption, which
is where you say,
hey, I would like
to go and receive these events
and put them over here--
a function or whatever.
And then it also unifies
the event production side
of things.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about that one.
But there's a
really nice model so
that you can think
about and reason
about the system
at the high level.
So let's look at these two
objects a little bit more
in detail.
So developers are probably
going to use this resource
the most, which
is really allowing
them to go ahead and say, hey,
when this event type happens,
please call this
function over here.
Today-- so some examples
of this would be like,
hey, when a PR is
put into a GitHub,
then do some things with that.
Right?
And we use this in
the Knative repo.
We have many of these
little robots that
do things like fix
spelling mistakes
or go ahead and make
sure that yaml looks
right and things like that.
So we are using
this in the Knative,
and it's really, really neat.
So that's a good
example for that.
Or you might want
to say, hey, you
know when objects
are loaded into GCS,
I want to go and receive
those, but only certain kinds.
So that's the concept
of the filtering there.
So the other nice thing
is that in this model,
the trigger or
your function code
can actually go ahead and
just return a new event type.
So if you, for example, want
to go ahead and say like,
hey, I want to take
some kind of an event.
But it might contain some
sensitive information
that I don't want
everybody else to see.
You can go ahead and either
create a new event or event
type, and then you can go and
feed it back in the system.
So it makes the function
writer's job much, much easier
on that sense.
So in this particular one, for
example, we are saying, hey,
I want to go and receive events
from com.example.some event.
And we are sending
it to a subscriber.
And if you're familiar
with Kubernetes or Knative,
that is basically
an object graph.
In this case, it is using
a service that's serving.
The other new event
is the event broker.
And this is really, I
personally think of it
as the event delivery
system or the mesh.
So when you come into a
namespace of your choosing,
and you decide that you want
to sprinkle some Knative
eventing on it, you can just
go ahead and apply a label
on that namespace.
And the Knative will
install a broker for you
in that namespace.
And as a side
effect of that, you
will now get a discoverable
endpoint/predictable endpoint
so that you can go
ahead now target
that event mesh from
any other namespace
or from the same
namespace as well.
So you can also install
multiple of these as well
into your namespace on
multiple namespaces.
And you might say, well,
why would I want to do that?
And really there's a couple
of different reasons.
But one of the
things that happens
underneath the
scenes for the broker
is the task to manage
some messaging layers.
So these are the channels, if
you've been using the Knative
eventing in the past.
And you might want to go
ahead and choose a couple
of different broker models.
So on one of them you
might want to say,
I don't want to lose
any of these events.
I'm willing to go and pay
the cost of processing them
into the persistent messaging.
And the other one is
where you might just
be doing some you don't care.
And you might
choose to go and do
things like in-memory
implementation
where if an event
gets lost, fine.
Rerun it again or whatnot.
So you have some options there.
But you get it for free if
you just label the namespace.
And you can also go and
use the broker object
for controlling access
and ingress policy
into that broker.
So you can say, for
example, I don't
want any events that I
have not pre-authorized
to enter this broker.
And that's one example of that.
The other one is where you're
doing some cheap and cheerful
testing, and you just
want to do stuff,
produce events willy
nilly and everything else.
So good luck with that.
The last one that
didn't unfortunately
make it to 0.5, but I just
wanted to point out here
is that this is the registry
that we are working refining
as a community right
now, making sure it's
nice, nice and usable.
And really, it's meant to
solve the use case of how
do you discover the event type.
So once you're in your broker
namespace or in your namespace,
you want to be able
to have an easy way
to discover what
event types there are,
what do they look
like, and so forth.
So this is something that the
registry is going to solve.
And we are working very hard to
get it into the next release.
So this is what it
really looks like.
Or at least how I see the world.
So if you think about from
the left-hand side there,
we have two event sources
that are processing events.
And they both--
so there's the red
and then there's
the blue source.
And they're both
pushing those events
into the broker where the broker
is happily receiving them.
And then a developer comes in
on the right-hand side there
and defines one of those
triggers where they
come in and saying, like, hey.
I am actually interested
in the red events.
So you create a
trigger, but you specify
that the filtering is red.
And now your service gets
called only for the red events.
And on the bottom side you
can probably guess that then
that one gets only
the blue events.
Right?
In both cases of the service
I just highlighted the fact
that it's callable, because
it's using something
that in the Knative we make
extensive use of to make
it easy to extend unpluggable.
It's duck typing concept
that Matt Moore and I have
been working on for a while.
So the nice thing
is that you can
put different kinds of things.
One of those is a Knative
service from the serving stack.
But you can put these things
into other places as well.
So let's go ahead and see what
this looks like in action.
Mark has cooked
up something neat.
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah.
So before we go there,
a little setup here.
Now this chart looks very--
this diagram looks very complex.
And we'll kind of break it down.
I kind of put a little
line around this
where are we going
to be focusing today.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to create a very
simplistic trigger that
will fire on a pops-up event.
Pops-up is a very simple
globally distributed
event messaging system
that's easy to consume.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to create a simple
trigger that will fire whenever
a new event arrives.
But I wasn't going to
create new events myself.
So what we're going
to do is actually
going to leverage one of the
events that already generated
by Cloud Build.
If you attended some
of the cloud run demos,
I've used that
demonstration there.
So we will fire simple build.
And whenever the build publishes
a new status of a build,
we'll attach to it
and fire an event.
Now events are great,
but not really meaningful
until you can see them.
So what are we going
to do in this case,
we're to send this
to Slack in order
to be able to display the
actual content of that.
So can we switch to
the demo machine?
I'll make sure Slack
is running too.
All right.
So first thing what
we're going to do--
can you see this?
Yeah.
It's pretty good.
So what we're gonna do
is we're going to look
at the trigger object in here.
So if you've worked
with Kubernetes before,
you should be very
familiar with the fact
that there is some namespace
for the API and the version.
In this case, we've created
a new object called Trigger.
That trigger allows
us to name it.
And for demo purposes,
I named it pretty long.
But you can name it
whatever you want.
We really go in with a
lot of defaults in here.
So we're using the
serving namespace
to be able to define
an addressable object.
In this case, our
addressable object
is going to be our Notification
Service building, the one we're
going to send those events to.
So let's go and fire this up.
So kubectl apply config.
Again, very Kubernetes-friendly
way of doing it.
There is number of CLIs
now that are already
available in the community
for Knative so that--
if you're coming
from Kubernetes,
you're very familiar
with kubectl.
You can run this anytime.
Right?
Or kubecattle, depends--
there's a battle still
to how to exactly pronounce it.
But if you're
familiar with that,
you can continue using that.
But there is a number of CLIs
available to actually hide
even that from you and allow
you to deal specifically only
with the Knative objects.
And canticle, or
KNCTL, is one of those.
Knative project has its own CLI
building being built right now.
So you're welcome to try this.
But in this case, we're going
to go straight to kubectl.
We're going to apply this.
How's the command line?
Big enough?
Yeah.
So what we've got messages
that the trigger was created.
But let's not trust
those messages.
Let's run get triggers.
And I'm running everything
in a demo namespace
just for isolation purposes.
But what you will
see here is that we
got the-- let me see if
I can make this bigger.
There we go.
You got the name, the
status, each trigger has
its internal URL-- obviously,
that's not accessible
externally-- and
the age in here.
So what we've done now is
we've set up the trigger.
That's all I had to do
in order to attach myself
to the source of events.
So let's generate
some events now.
Very quickly before
we even go there,
let's take a look at
that actual service.
That service is really
just for demo purposes.
But what it does has a couple
of interesting things here.
First of all, there's
a handler that whenever
it receives those cloud events--
remember, we talked about
the transport always using
cloud events so you can
trust that the type you're
going to be getting is going
to be [INAUDIBLE] cloud events.
We're going to get
one of those types.
We're going to extract the
actual message of that.
And then we're going to
send it to a sender that
decorates nice message.
And then at very end, it
just sends it to Slack.
And hopefully, if everything
goes well-- fingers crossed--
in our demo we're going to
be able to go in and see
the status being published.
So let's go to--
I have a simple
pipeline setup here.
So again, I don't have
to build anything myself.
We're going to create
a simple new release.
Going to give some name.
Knative trigger demo.
Obviously, you should be
doing some better releases.
But since you are
watching over here,
I'm just going to say no
release notes, very sad.
And submit.
So Cloud Build
gives us a easy way
to kind of get in kind of
peek at what's going on.
So there's one fired already.
I'm not going to go through
all these details of what
happens here.
Cloud Build gives you an easy
way to kind of attach yourself
to social repository.
This one is firing on a label--
sorry-- on a tag.
You can do this on the
branches and all that.
But let's go to our Slack and
see what's going on over there.
Hopefully this is all public.
So it's not like
any secrets in here.
Knative channel.
We see our notification
arrived for next demo
25 starting working.
If I waited long enough,
if I went to the status
and waited for that
to finish Built,
it would eventually send
another status change saying,
I was working.
Now I'm finished.
And the finish status was built.
You can actually go and it
gives you a link in here.
This is just a demo channel.
So you can clearly see
that the messages are not
formatted exactly perfectly.
But once the build
finishes in here,
you will see one of those
status has changed to success.
So can we change back
to the slides, please?
So back to our channels here.
Those events could be anything.
Ville was talking about
the number, like, get hops
and pushes and everything.
The process would
be one and the same.
You go in and create a trigger.
You attach the trigger to
some kind of event source.
And we will go into the
event sources in a minute.
And then you also send who is
the consumer of those events.
And in this case was
a notification service
that adheres to that interface.
And we send it.
So pretty simple.
Pretty easy.
There's a number of
those demonstration
in Knative samples.
And you can kind of
reproduce this pretty easily
on your own Knative cluster.
Whoop.
VILLE AIKAS: Good catch.
All right.
So one of the things that
we didn't talk about yet,
but let's talk about them now.
So we've really focused on what
the developer experience is
there where they can come
in and say, like, hey,
here's my trigger.
It was very easy to set up.
You basically just said, I
want those kind of events.
I want them go over here, right?
That was nice.
There was no mention of how
did those events show up
in the cluster.
OK.
And it's not magic,
it turns out.
We haven't figured that out.
So there is some stuff
you have to do to get
those events into your cluster.
And by utilizing
these event sources,
the user is going to care about
a couple of different things.
They are going to
care about, OK,
how do I actually get
those events then?
Right.
So you want to be able to
discover these event sources.
So for example, if
you're like, OK.
I really would like to go ahead
and build my own little GitHub
robot or whatever else.
So how would I do that?
So you're going to be able to
discover that there is a GitHub
event source out there for you.
Right?
And you also want to be able to
configure those external event
sources, because you have
to be able to do things
like, for example, in the GitHub
you want to be able to say,
I need to go ahead
and watch events
on this particular
bucket owner or repo--
project and repo.
And you want to be able
to specify those ones.
And lastly, you want to
be able to go and say,
but that's great.
But I have my own
internal system.
And I'm sure nobody is going to
write an event source for that.
So you always have the
option of writing yourself
and be able to go ahead
and use it internally.
But hopefully you
can come in and write
some other external ones
and come play with us.
So Knative Event community has
already built many of these.
So here is just a very, very
small sample of the ones.
But you can see the rich
set of event sources
that you can go and come
in and start using today.
But many of these
are in the repo.
Some of them are in the
different kinds of repos,
because they are maintained by
different people and so forth.
But on the bottom
there is a link that
contains all the event sources.
And if you write
one, and you want
to go ahead and come
in and expose it
to a wider set of
users, then you
can go ahead and add it to
the list and to send out a PR.
So let's go and see what
does it look like to go
and actually go ahead and use
one of these event sources.
So first demo we
talked about, events
were all wired up to
come into the broker.
And all you needed to do was
to go and create a trigger
to go ahead and consume those.
So now let's go and complete the
picture and saying, like, yay.
OK.
Now let's go to
look at the magic--
which, it's not
magic-- but what does
that look like
when I go and say,
please give me events
of certain type?
So Mark.
MARK CHMARNY: All right.
So again, back to a quick
overview before we get there.
I'm going to trust you today.
I'm going to ask
you to actually use
your devices to post something
so we can display any here.
Ville is going to
hold the finger
on closing the window whenever
something doesn't work.
I'm sure the HR team is going
to come and send me an email
afterwards.
But what we're
going to do is we're
going to create a very simple--
we're going to configure
a brand new event
source for tweets that are
matching a specific query.
You can guess its going to be--
I will tell you the
query in a minute.
So you don't have too much time.
The other thing
we're going to do
is we're going to go in and
configure different trigger,
but using the same pattern.
We just have done this
for the built status.
So we're going to
create a source.
We're going to create a trigger.
Then we're going to open
a Knative service that's
a basic UI application that's
going to display those tweets.
Now you have to be
authenticated to Twitter
so we know who you are.
But I'm trusting a lot
into this whole process.
All right.
Can you switch to the demo?
So in this case
back to our yaml.
You're going to be in yaml a lot
if you're working on a Knative.
We're obfuscating a lot of
that through CLI sometimes.
But in some more complex cases
you still have to use yaml.
So in this case we're going
to use a brand new object
type called Container Source.
Ville will talk about those.
That's one of the
types of sources
that we can integrate
into Knative.
As you can guess it, I called
this the Twitter source.
Here is your handle.
So start typing.
Please don't give me in trouble.
The other thing we've
got to do in here
is we're going to
actually start using
some more advanced features.
So for example, in this case,
I wouldn't want to show you,
especially when it's recorded,
tokens for my account
to connect to Twitter, right?
That would not be wise.
So we're using
Kubernetes secrets.
That's something you can do.
We can use both Kubernetes
secrets as well as volumes,
if that's a easier
pattern to use secrets.
We're going to
deploy an image that
represents the
actual source that's
going to be consuming this.
We're also going to do a
couple other things in here.
We're going to create a broker.
And we're going to go to
a default broker in here.
So let's switch over here.
And the first thing
we're going to do is--
this is source.
Yeah.
Let's deploy this.
Again, let's get the sources.
Come on.
There it is.
So we see the original
pops up that I
was using in a previous demo.
But here is my brand
new 11-second-old event
source for this.
So that's one.
The other thing we were
saying we're going to be doing
is we're going to be
creating a trigger.
You've already seen
a trigger, so I'm
going to focus on a couple
of new bits in here.
First we adding a
filter, saying there
could be any number of
different types of events.
And Ville talked about
those different types
when he was overviewing
the trigger.
What are we using in here is
all I want to subscribe to is
those Twitter triggers.
A lot of T's.
Sorry.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to define the type.
This is really
[INAUDIBLE] string.
But it's using a
pattern that's kind
of common for these
events, com.Twitter.
And we're going to
send this to a UI event
that looks like this.
So hopefully when
everything goes well
a very nicely formatted
and clean tweet
is going to show up
here in a minute.
All right.
Let's do-- oh, we
have to install it.
Nothing happened until
you actually do this.
So let's clear.
kubectl.
Apply.
Config.
And this is the trigger.
And make sure we're
going into the same demo.
All right.
So this is created.
Let's just make sure it's there.
I don't know I should be
trusting Knative to just
be there for me.
It never disappoints me.
All right.
So--
VILLE AIKAS: Yay!
MARK CHMARNY: Yeah!
I should close this right now.
So you can build a very
robust set of features.
Can we switch to slide?
Thank you very much, JTronson.
Thank you very much.
What we've done, we've
done the entire pipeline
by creating brand new source.
Ville is going to overview how
to create the actual source
itself, the code.
But we configured that
source on a cluster.
We then went in and
created a trigger.
You can have n numbers
of those triggers that
listen to that same source.
And we've defined
the trigger that
connects that output
of those events,
or the events themselves,
and fires a particular event.
So anything targetable
will work there.
And Ville will overview
what that means.
Right now simple service
was a good example of that.
We were using also web
sockets example of here
that was able to kind of refresh
the page without me doing that.
That's a new couple of new
features-- couple new transport
supports that we've
added, including
GRPC, HDTP2, web sockets.
Am I missing anything?
No.
All right.
So simple demo.
Easy to follow.
You can easily reproduce
that one as well
as many other ones,
again, in samples
Knative repository
in the samples repo.
VILLE AIKAS: All right.
So there's a couple
of nice things
that you get out of using
event sources, right.
So if you have used
GitHub or Twitter or any
of these other systems that
already produce, or are
capable of emitting events,
you can go and go out today
and go to some web page or tools
and create these for yourself
and point them at
something else as well.
With the event
sources, the benefits
of using them in this way
is that it actually means
that they are declarative.
Right?
So you can go ahead and
create these in your cluster.
You can actually see them.
So as Mark was showing
there, you can say,
what are the subscriptions
that I have going on for me
right now?
You don't have to go
ahead and remember
how things are done in
the sense that creating
web hooks and various websites,
it's always different,
and it's difficult to remember
how they were created,
and there's all these
how-to pages, and so forth.
So by using the
event sources you
can do this all declaratively.
You can check into conflicts
into your source control,
which I'm sure
you are all doing,
because conflict is code.
So you are doing all
the right things.
And they also reconcilable.
So if you make changes
those event sources,
then all the right things
happen for you underneath.
So the source is then
responsible for taking
care of that on the
authoritative side.
So that's really, really nice.
And the last bit is that there's
a now very clear separation
of concerns so that
the broker is basically
creating a nice little
eventing mesh that
takes in all the events.
And then the user focuses
on routing those events
to the appropriate
functions by using triggers.
So that's nice.
And then on the other side
we have these event sources
that are responsible for
then establishing the control
plane and the data plane and
ensuring that those events are
now delivered in the broker.
So there's a nice new
clean separation there.
So while the Knative
community has
provided many of
these event sources
already, as I mentioned
earlier, there's
probably some that
we haven't done yet.
I know there's a lot of
them that we haven't done.
And you might also have
some internal systems.
Do you want to go
ahead and say, it
would be really nice if that
thing that I already have
would produce events for me.
And we think that's
saying, great.
Just rewrite it so that it's
cloud native is probably
not the best answer.
So we can go ahead
and make sure that we
can take these bits of code
in the form of event sources
and kind of bridge those
two worlds together.
So let's look a
little bit at this
and see what is sort of involved
in building one of these event
sources.
So there's really two concerns
that you have to think about.
So one of them is
the control plane.
So the control plane is
the one where you are
asking some external system--
external to brokers.
When I say "external,"
I don't really
care whether it's
internal or external.
But I do think that it's
outside of the broker's realm.
So it's external to the broker.
So there's a
control plane action
where you are asking some
system to go ahead and start
sending you events that
are filtered according
to your specification.
So here are some examples.
Creating a GitHub web hook
for a particular repository
and defining what kinds of event
types you might care about.
So PRs, commits, comments,
and things like that.
Or creating a GCP PubSub
subscription or GCS
object storage
notification and so forth.
I'm sure you can
all hopefully think
of a couple of other systems
that are not on that list.
And then there is also the
concern about the data plane.
So it's great that you
have asked somebody
to send you events.
But where are they going
to be sent to, right?
So that is the concern
of the data plane.
So in this case, for
example, we can go ahead
and create a data plane
component that receives
the GitHub web hook events.
Or we can go ahead and
have a piece of software
that is running on
our cluster that
is responsible for
handling pull models,
because there's both
kinds of models out there.
So there's push and
pull based ones.
So on the control plane--
so while on the
broker side of things
we are standardizing
on the cloud events,
and there's a nice little
control plane component there
that allows you to do that.
There is nothing like
that, unfortunately,
out there that allows
us to go and have
a standard way of subscribing
to events everywhere.
And I don't think that that's
going to happen anytime soon.
But it may be.
That would be nice.
But if you look at, for example,
when Mark was demonstrating
the Twitter example,
there was things that he
had to go and specify, like--
I don't know-- credentials.
Right?
So credentials come in
different kinds of format.
So the control plane
has to be customized
for a particular event so that
it knows how to authenticate
itself and so forth.
They also all have
different custom APIs.
The nice thing is
that many of these--
there's many, many libraries
that you can go and pull
in the form of your
own choosing, language
of your choice.
And then it also
has to reconcile.
So I basically-- I mentioned
earlier that if I make changes
to the Twitter example
and reapply those changes,
then the Twitter
source is going to be
responsible for pushing those
and modifying the control plane
bits as necessary.
And the second bit that the
control plane needs to do
is as it is setting up the
control plane it obviously
needs to go and
point it at something
and establish the data plane.
So the event source is also
responsible for setting up
the data plane components.
And a couple of reasons
for that are, well, there's
probably some
authentication that
has to happen at
the data plane also.
Right?
So if you, for example,
set up a GitHub web
hook, then one of the ways
that you can authenticate
there is by using
a shared secret.
So the source is going to go
and set up a Brando secret,
give it to GitHub, because
nobody else cares about it,
gives it to GitHub and
gives it to data plane.
And then you're
off to the races.
And then obviously,
control plane
needs to go ahead and
clean up after it's done.
So once you decide that maybe
you don't want this anymore,
it's responsible now for
going in and deleting
the external sources
so that you don't
have to remember say,
like, oh, I don't want
to receive those events now.
Here's a piece of
documentation that
tells you how to undo all the
stuff that you did before.
So really this just
a simple picture
where the event source
on the left hand--
the yellow ones, those are
the custom pieces of code
that run on your cluster.
So there's two of them there.
There's a GitHub and a GCS.
And both of them are
talking to a control plane.
One of them, the GitHub
API, using the green one.
And one of them
to cloud storage.
And they are just
establishing that data plane
on the right-hand side
there to the broker.
That's what they're
conceptually saying.
Please go and send those events.
Send them over to the
broker over there.
Well, that's nice.
But then this is where you
have to worry about things
like the date plane, right?
So while everything
within Knative eventing
is cloud events, so the broker
says, I only take cloud events.
Right?
Nice separation of concerns.
So the data plane
is going to have
to normalize those
events that are coming in
from the external sources,
convert them into cloud events,
and hand them off
over to the broker.
They also need to,
as I mentioned,
deal with the authentication
and authorization.
So just because
somebody sends you
an event from the
outside world, you
want to make sure
that it actually is
the one that you subscribed to.
So that's where the
coordination between the control
plane of the event source
and the data plane--
there's some coordination
that needs to happen.
And again, there's
pull versus push.
So some examples
are for GCP PubSub.
You can run in both modes.
You can run it in pull
mode or push mode.
So depending on how you want to
go ahead and set up your data
plane, you have choices there.
Push base obviously lends itself
very nicely to Knative serving,
so that many of these event
sources that are push-based
are implemented using
just a Knative service.
Yes.
And so.
So it roughly looks like this.
So that we kind of covered
everything about the broker on.
So the first part was the
control plane-- the yellows.
Now here's sort of the
data plane for you.
So you can see that the--
for example, the
FTP receive adapter
that we have
written, for example,
is the one that is pull-based.
Because many of the
FTP servers out there
don't expose a
push-based model, or they
don't expose any notifications.
So you have to go ahead
and do something like this.
But this is a good
example of being
able to take a little bit of
glue code and saying, you know,
now all of a sudden
without changing anything
on the original source that
you cared about, you can go
and write a little
bit of [? shin ?] code
and go and print those eventing
capabilities now to an existing
system out there.
And then GitHub and GCS.
So they are all sending
different kinds of events.
Off they go into their
respective receive adapters.
And out comes nice,
normalized cloud events
that then get handed
off to the broker.
Obviously, they all contain
different kinds of payloads.
So if you look at the
one on the bottom there,
there's a quick example of
what do these magical cloud
events look like.
So there's this kind of
standard envelope around it.
And then the payload
goes in the data there.
So it's very easy for
the function writers
to go ahead and
reason about these.
MARK CHMARNY: Seven minutes.
VILLE AIKAS: All right.
So there's basically
three standard base today
to go and write event sources.
So one of them is the, I want
to go and do it all myself.
I want to write a
Kubernetes controller,
because that is fun.
And that's a lot of work.
So we came up with something
called Knative Container
Source.
I'll talk a little
bit about that one.
And then the last bit
is where you already
have some running code
that you have control over.
And you want to
go and just start
emitting events from there.
So the Kubernetes
Operator is basically
this is a standard way that
you basically add a new object
type in the Kubernetes.
You basically define
a CRD says this
is what the objects look like.
And then you write a controller
that sits there and looks
at those objects and
reconciles the world.
And then you have
web hook that is
authenticating and
validating and defaulting
and things like that.
So it's only three pieces.
But it's a lot of work.
Trust me.
I've written a few of these.
So that's a lot of work.
And it's very complicated to
get it right and so forth.
There's a great example
that actually uses
this with just a GCP PubSub.
So I'm not going to
go through the code.
But there it is.
You can go look at it.
So what we did at the
Knative, we're like, OK.
Look.
It's really, really hard.
So let's go ahead and write one
controller that is easy for you
to reason about,
because you just
say, hey, when a
new event type gets
created-- like the Twitter.
So good example of this
is the Twitter one.
So when we showed
you the Twitter one,
the Twitter source is using
the container storage.
So you basically
just say like, look.
I don't want to write a
Kubernetes controller.
I'm just going to
give you a container.
Can you run this for
me when you go ahead
and establish a
new subscription,
modify it, and delete it.
So that's what you can do
with the container source.
You just give us a controller--
uh, controller-- container.
And we run it for you.
And the nice thing is
it's language neutral.
So whatever code you have,
just wrap it up in a container
and bring it to us.
And with this model
you can also go ahead
and it's possible to combine
the control and data plane.
And one example of this is
the Kubernetes event source.
So this is the
Kubernetes event source
that runs on your cluster.
It watches for Kubernetes
events and turns them
into Knative events for you.
So then you can go and do things
like automate some aspects
of your Kubernetes cluster
yourself and things like that.
And there's obviously
more code here.
But really, really-- and
there's a link to it.
But the only things that
it really cares about,
it sets up the control
plane on there,
basically uses Kubernetes
client and says,
I want to go ahead and start
watching for event types--
Kubernetes events.
And when those
events happen, please
call this little
function for me.
And that's the add
event function there.
And the only thing
that function has to do
is take that, wrap it
up in a cloud event,
and ship it off the broker.
And you are done.
So that is a pretty
simple one to do.
And then let's say you already
have some code running.
And this is our super
secure log-in service here,
for example, where the only
thing we want to do is we
have some running code.
And we have some
places where we would
like to go ahead and extend
that system by emittting
some events.
So all we have to do is from
that existing code decide where
we want to send the events--
sorry-- when do you want to
emit events and instantiate
a new Cloud Events client.
So in this case, it's
our own internal events.
I just wrap it up
in a cloud event.
And my data is then
whatever you want it to be.
Right?
So those are the
kind of three ways
of doing it in the order of
decreasing difficulty, if you
will.
And there's a cloud events SDK.
There's one good example,
the cloud events repo,
as I mentioned the spec
theories say that's a Go
lang, because this is Go Lang.
But you can use that, so
it's pretty easy for you
to go ahead and do this
yourself if you want to.
MARK CHMARNY: All right.
We've barely made it on time.
But hopefully we gave you a good
overview of the Knative events
and the capabilities they're in.
It's very hard to kind of go
super deep but also fit it
all in an hour and level set.
There is a lot of examples that
are available on the Knative
website.
If you go to our Knative.dev
and drill down into samples,
you will see all different
simple events all the way
to very complex ones.
And you can kind
of pace yourself.
We also have walked through
some of the spectrum of the way
you can interact with events.
You can start with
very simplistic one
where it might not be able
to reconcile your sources,
and migrate over time to
something more complex.
Again, a lot of
those event sources
have already been written.
So you don't have to
be in that business
unless you don't want
to-- unless you want to.
So hopefully this was
good informative session.
There's a couple links in here
where you can get hold of us
as well as ask some deeper
questions on a Knative slack.
It's just
accessKnative.slack.com
That will redirect to
to the Slack directly.
And you can ask the
different channels
for eventing, community, the
general one, which always good
place to start with.
And obviously, this week we have
kind of announced Cloud Run.
Cloud Run doesn't
support cloud events yet
for this kind of service.
But as you can imagine, we are
looking forward to the time
where we can offer
that service too.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]